you ready for this this is your first
film after that moonlight success
everyone is it has been buzzing about it
already as an Oscar contender what makes
this one more special than moonlight
well I mean I don't have any kids but if
I had them I would say none of my kids
is more special than the others to be
brutally honest we tried to approach it
in a way where it wasn't different you
know we're just people were trying to
tell stories when I say us and speaking
of myself my cinematographer the editors
the producers you know all these people
who I've known since I was like 20 21
years old we just always had this dream
of being able to tell very interesting
rich stories and I feel like this book
falls in line with that
it's your green child what difference
does it make how it gets here I'm bow
your heads
a few themes in this film stuck stuck
out to me social injustice pregnancy out
of wedlock which are taboos what about
this James Baldwin novel struck you to
tell this story yeah I've always been a
big fan of mr. Baldwin's work and I
loved in this miss Filmore in this book
how so many different voices mr. Baldwin
speaks with refused in the story to
speak on some of the things you
mentioned what I love is that all these
things the families dealing with this
out-of-wedlock pregnancy this thing that
happens to tafani all of us treat it
without shame in a certain way we are
drinking to new life Tish gonna have
funnies baby I just love how the family
unit unites around these two young
lovers and to me when I read the book
and hopefully you watch the film or
soulmates which cuts through the idea of
marriage or wedlock or any of those
things what I love about it is that Bill
Street could be anywhere and I know
you're from Florida what would your
hometown say about your upbringing um I
think they would say it's very similar
to the upbringing of these characters
but also the character and moonlight as
well God lived in a neighborhood and a
community that was a bit wild to be
honest and I grew up in the age of crack
cocaine so it was very dark to be even
more honest but there was always love
somewhere and there was a really strong
sense of community it was amazing and
one of the most commanding actresses on
screen was Miss Regina Kane talked to me
about the favorite scene that you had
shooting with her that was a scene where
the two families come together which is
really wonderful to work on but I think
my favorite moment working with Regina
was when it was just her and her
reflection and a mirror where did the
scene where she's having this difficulty
getting herself ready for this big
confrontation and it's just her and her
reflection in the mirror and we only did
it from two angles and it was just
really lovely to see how how brave and
committed she was to doing something
that was almost like a silent film
moment in this very talking movie with
the Oscars buzz that's been going on
Damien is also gonna be up front with
first man how does it feel to be in the
mix with him again after that la-la-land
mix-up um I mean the mix-up was was one
thing that was very interesting in
bizarre I don't wanna speak for Damien
but you know he didn't make it Billy
Street not to make first man and we had
made the same film then it would feel
like we're in competition or
mix up or something like that but I
think we're all just trying to tell
stories and they end up where they end
up yeah and I love that I love that
there's no competition Kiki and Stefan
what do you think people are gonna say
about their chemistry and I think what
they'll see when they see these two
beautiful young black people misses very
rich depiction of just soulmates you
know I think Kiki and Stefan she's his
wonderful job of creating and very pure
pure love
[Music]